the next item is now the
statements of the board of the
committee on
welfare conditions of animals during
transport in third countries
I remind you dear colleagues and dear colleagues
that it is possible to apply for the
ai cash procedure and the blue card
using it both the
standard registration  both the electronic system
directly from your workstations the
instructions are available at the entrance to the
courtroom and now name of the council the
floor again to the minister to pura in
trees of modern dance team six months
activation of counsel concludes sense
animal welfare conclusions animal
production
continues
on the web effective enforcement of
existing the sisley son in fact kill on
input exchange of invention of member
states and active fooders the mission
statement morris technique been discussed
in this context stakeholders the face
ring international aspect in comparisons
including quito
thank you very much to the ministry and
now  on behalf of the c  omission of the
word commissioner who
shoots achilles drop paulina media and flights
compared to flashes of fake sense of work
and must
not least win conference top management
fortis trani from terence doris customers or
north
i.e. phobia sharing in markets
livestock fashion week end  of the day of
action conditions including scariest
opoli thank you very much dear commissioners
now on behalf of the Group of the
European People's Party